hey guys welcome back to another
session by simply learn today's topic of
discussion
is java versus python so in this session
we're going to compare the two most
prominently used
languages that is java and python we're
also going to help you
choose the appropriate programming
language depending on your requirements
if you haven't subscribed to our channel
already i'd really suggest you hit the
subscribe button and the bell icon to
never miss an update
all right i'm sure we've all been in
this position
where we've had to choose between java
and python
and it was so confusing so today let me
help you choose between the two
languages
and look at what's in store for us
first we have an introduction to both
java
and python then we will compare the
fundamental concepts of both
these languages
after that we will get to know the
various fields in which these languages
are being used extensively
then we will go through the current
industry trends and the salaries offered
to these developers
and finally we will reach to a
conclusion and decide for ourselves
which language is good for us according
to our requirements
so let's start the session by first
getting to know both java and python
java was developed by sun micro systems
it is a fairly robust and high level
language
it is an object-oriented language and so
adheres to all the oops concepts
like abstraction and encapsulation
it was originally designed for use in
small hardware like set-up boxes
and handheld devices but due to the
increasing popularity
of internet in those times it was very
quickly modified to be used in the world
wide web
moving on what exactly is python now you
won't believe this but python was
created in the year 1989
like java it is also object oriented and
is a high level language
it incorporates many english words in
its syntax
as it was designed to be significantly
more readable than other programming
languages
it is mainly used for artificial
intelligence machine learning and web
development
so now that you've been introduced to
both java and python
let's go ahead and compare the
fundamental concepts of both these
languages
first up is speed java is a statically
typed language
which means the syntax is checked at
compile time and so the execution speed
is faster opposingly python is a
dynamically typed language so the syntax
is checked at the time of execution this
makes the execution speed slower when
compared to java
next up is syntax python has a clear
advantage when it comes to the amount of
code we have to write
for performing the same task you can
point out how
simple it is to print a hello world in
python when compared to java
python automatically sets the type of
variable according to its value
java on the other hand needs the type of
variable to be defined
before the compilation of the code
java is more commonly used for web and
mobile applications
while python is mainly used for data
science machine learning and internet of
things
i'm sure by now you have a good
understanding of these languages
so let's go ahead and see where they're
used more commonly
first up let's see the use cases of java
it is commonly used for developing web
and mobile applications
java is extensively used in enterprise
applications because of its stability
and also because of the large number of
features that it provides for business
applications
android applications are mainly
developed using java
now let's see the use cases of python
python is very popular
for the use in the field of artificial
intelligence
it is also used for web development
mostly for the backend part of an
application
youtube is mostly written in python
on let's go through the industry trends
and salaries for both python and java
developers
the graph represents the growth of both
the languages over the last five years
we can make out that python has picked
up over time and has become more popular
than java in recent times
this is mainly due to the increasing
popularity of data science fields
moving on to the salaries the average
salary of a java developer in india
is around 4.5 lakhs per annum
the average salary of a java developer
in the us is around 80
000 us dollars
moving on to python the average salary
of a python developer in
india is around 4 lakhs per annum
since people pursue python mostly
because they are interested in the field
of data science
the salary dramatically increases when
they get a suitable role say data
scientist
data scientists get paid on an average
of 10 lakhs per annum
the average salary of a python developer
in the united states
is around 76 000 us dollars
if they get into data science roles
their average sanity spikes up to around
110
000 us dollars
moving on to the last topic on our
agenda here we conclude
as to which programming language is
suitable for you depending on your
requirements
let's now think about why we'd want to
go with one of these languages
here are some points to keep in mind
choose java if you are more into
software engineer roles and want to
handle systems for large corporations
java is extensively used for developing
android applications
so if you want to build an application
for android os java should be your clear
choice
java is also suitable for building
various standalone end-to-end softwares
that run on the pcs if you are into this
sort of thing
then java is the language for you
on the other hand if you are interested
in the fields of artificial intelligence
data science or the internet of things
python is the go-to language for those
sorts of technologies
python is very simple to understand so
if you're learning to code for the very
first time
i'd suggest you go with python if you're
interested in web development
python can be a good choice as it
provides excellent frameworks like
django and flask to facilitate web
development
with that we come to the end of this
session if you're learning any one of
these
programming languages be it java or
python let us know which one it is
in the chat section below and if you're
yet to decide on one of these languages
then i suggest you do your thorough
research before arriving at a decision
and thank you so much for being here
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here